un foyer français sur deux est connecté
à internet c'est beaucoup mais c'est
moins que la moyenne de nos voisins
européens lors des campagnes sont
organisés pour y intéresser les français
notamment les seniors enquête nicolas le
mari de nathalie gallet vous choisissez
en eau
sur quels trucs que vous voulez les
trucs et les machins d'internet suzanne
garnier voulez découvrir depuis un
moment alors à 83 ans
et si enfin mise et elle cherche quelque
chose de très précis cathy des eaux et
course et donc ça sur internet ça vous
intéresse je pense qu'il y aura je ne
connais pas encore ma faim je pense
qu'ils galèrent à fournir oui ça
m'intéresse
il fait ça ça va rien faire de plus pour
tanguy mais qu'il disait images normand
produite pour la technique c'est bien
connu il faut faire appel aux plus
jeunes
alors c'est son voisin d'ordinateurs 71
ans qui lui explique alors ils marchent
recherche double aujourd'hui en france
ils sont deux millions et demi de
retraités comme ces deux là à s'être
mise au net mais je fais plutôt des
semailles
ou alors je m'interroge différents sites
aussi bien géographique au subie à
sociale enfin différencier dans ce
centre d'action sociale du 12e
arrondissement de paris il suffit de
s'inscrire pour venir consulter
gratuitement internet ou recevoir une
formation pour la quarantaine d'adeptes
de retraités il a fallu souvent commencé
par un peu d'exercice manouche âge les
premières difficultés se sont les
eddy seel quelle manipulation avec la
souris avec le kiel avec le clavier
notamment également des problèmes pour
qu'ils tuent au bon endroit sur le
moniteur pour pas se tromper
1 apporte commencer le fait qu'ils ont
maintenant dans les magasins spécialisés
en informatique on rencontre de plus en
plus de seniors autant de femmes que
d'hommes et même les publicités pour
internet s'intéresse désormais aux
retraités
les seniors n'ont pas fini de clics